doesn't the sanctity of marriage also
rely on the woman being a virgin so you
wouldn't be able to get married
that was petty but like how do you meet
a guy that you respect because he's
settling on you don't you see that
there's a paradox here
then you'll post called her the female
Andrew Tate so she tapped into genuine
female pushed back to the accessories of
wokory or is she just an attention
seeker we'll find out a moment but first
let's take a look at the clip of Senator
viral
people think I'm insane because I don't
think women should vote everybody thinks
I'm crazy for this opinion that dress is
crazy
that dress is crazy Strawberry Fields
Forever I would not normally care but
it's just like this girl's preaching
everyone they're too masculine or
whatever they're not fit to be wise and
I'm just like this is what I imagine a
Mormon stylist would look like but
everybody thinks I'm crazy for this
opinion if anything this is probably my
most extreme opinion 95 of women are not
virgins on their wedding days so I
understand the complaint
okay well Paul John uh oh okay okay
let's go see you can do it let's go with
it with a little pearl necklace you
don't think I see the touch yes
[Music]
CCM did that so proud of you okay you
look at the eye today yeah you're still
dumb as [__] but you look at all right
good job congratulations good job just
been alongside political journalist Ava
centene he was nodding furiously along
there to everything she heard I hate
this girl this girl's always on [__]
Piers Morgan singing she's so dumb you
don't like her the girl beside the Pearl
you don't like her she like she like the
the the feminine side of like the dumb
side argument you don't like this I
don't know she was there for like the
Jordan Peterson stuff and some of the
Andrew take the base and like she just
always had dumb takes all right Paul you
become it would be called the female
Andrew take how do you played
well I take it as a compliment you know
I'm a fan of Andrew Tate you're talking
about women predominantly
um which is why you've got this big
following and your view is that modern
feminism is deeply flawed I would argue
a lot of your proposals like taking the
vote away from them are deeply
regressive why would you want to remove
just from yourself the right to vote
well it also goes back to responsibility
um
again men are 80 to 90 percent of the
military they run all of the
infrastructures that make Society run
so I just think if we want an equal say
in society then be equal do 50 of the
hard jobs be 50 of the military in the
U.S um I think the whole argument about
you know men do the more dangerous jobs
so they should be the only ones to vote
is so dumb to me because I'm like I'm in
the military and I'm doing the more
dangerous job why should you a male
who's a civilian not do a dangerous job
get to a vote the same as me forget
women I don't give up the only people in
your world if we're using your logic to
the extreme why should a dude who shares
the same [__] genitalia get to vote
just like me if you're not doing the
same job I'm out there on the front
lines dying right if I'm doing the
military job why should a [__]
civilian be the one to tell me who I'm
gonna go kill and vote by voting why
should anybody who doesn't do a hard job
but she doesn't think that because her
logic it's only gendered okay and it's
only meant to appeal to men that's how
she plays for her team there is no
reason to explain this difference even
even someone that goes going to war not
everybody that goes to war is equal I am
sorry true Special Forces Cooks on a
boat and Generals yeah this is not the
same [__] Danger let's go let's talk
about it if you're on the field you get
three votes if you're on the fields but
you say on the boat you get one vote and
a half if you're General you get 75 of a
vote listen let's be honest about this
if danger or difficult jobs is the
metric by which then there's a lot of
men who don't get to vote and what about
the women who go to the military and
they do the dangerous jobs too should
they be allowed to what about any woman
who does a job which involves a lot of
death should she be allowed to vote
she's not making a coherent logic based
off the merits it's just gender nonsense
I just don't understand that if it's
just going to be about dangerous work
make it about that say that the people
who put their lives on the line should
have the most amount to lose and that
and I could at least get behind that Ava
your mouth seems to have dropped
everything I know I know it's just sort
of a galaxy brain I feel like you know
the statute of putting down a perhaps
correct in some years they just kind of
don't really add up I mean just just to
take you back to the to the women's
right writings that you've allegedly
read I mean absolutely
no just let the people talk you know Pro
want to make fun of feminists saying
they're so masculine but you're the one
that can't shut the [__] up when someone
else is talking she lets you speak
bro want to tell everybody how they're
not right to be wives but here you are
you can't shut the [__] up you want
programs putting yourself front and
center want to make the most amount of
money hey I'm just saying you the
opposite of everything you preaching
every chance you still [__] it up shut
up let her speak it's crazy that the
feminist seems more feminine letting her
speak speaking softly
allegedly
relax man that you're talking about you
know women weren't really allowed to
write they weren't allowed to go to
school
that's incorrect the first female
property the first female property owner
was in the 1600s the idea that women
couldn't work
no the first no no the first female the
first female millionaire was in the late
1800s this is how you know Pearl is like
such a disingenuous clown they're both
wrong about this could women work in the
16th century yeah but it was limited
jobs stuff like weaving and things that
were already late at the housework and
even then they didn't have equal pay for
this stuff no they didn't have any labor
rights they weren't even allowed to
dictate any kind of workplace anything
listen way that men could and they
weren't allowed to occupy most
occupations or jobs I'm not going to
talk about stuff that required physical
or just any job they weren't allowed to
have it was very very limited so Pearl's
in here but no the women could work they
couldn't even choose higher education
they couldn't go to university they
couldn't do any of this stuff it was
quartered off to them by their gender
yeah but the first homeowner was in the
1600. yeah I mean like how did she get
that house it makes me think of that
time where Pearl brought up that study
that said women find men who do chores
really unattractive and it's like a
study from the night like 1991 in the
cosmo yeah
even though she got more recent studies
she's gonna go to the only number that
basically drives with what she want to
say and then she gonna say I do my
research no
it's fine to concede on this point yes
women were second-class citizens in the
16 17 1800s it's okay
it's only I think in the 19th century
where women really started to
participate in the labor force due to
like Wars and stuff like that was
absolutely necessary and then a lot of
Rights came after effect it's just probe
doing just pearly things right listen
let's get on to the vote so what I don't
understand is you know a part of your
message I've just you know I've
researched you today and hang on a
minute okay you know your big push is
that you care about men and you don't
think that men are getting enough of a
say hang on I haven't made the point yet
I've seen her in the girl did not
interrupt her a single time and she's
interrupted her five six times
I can't [__] Pearl State being the
less feminine girl I know
um because of feminism okay what I
wonder is when you start making calls
that like repeal the 19th women
shouldn't be allowed to vote how is that
helping young men because these young
men have women in their lives they have
mothers they have sisters they have
teachers and they turn around they don't
know how to act around women because
you're giving them license to be
misogynistic I wouldn't call it
misogynistic I say be equal so again
well then okay I'd love for the
feminists please apply for the oil rigs
please go do the hard jobs in society
they're open they're hiring because I
don't equate for I don't think men or
women are equal until we do the equal
work Pearl bringing up the whole
equality thing is like you know
maybe I'm just not aware what's being
said in these circles well it's not like
women don't contribute to our society in
terms of the workforce I think women
will account for like it's like 30 it's
like one-third of the country's GDP
right so in terms of economic
contributions in terms of their work
they're a huge contributor if women were
to do what Pearl wants him to do which
is go home
stay there be Housewives don't have jobs
whatever the [__] it would be economy
would collapse like women are like
integral to the workforce so imagine
looking at people who contribute so much
and saying we're gonna deny you the
right to have any say the country's
future does that even seem remotely fair
to you guys does it make sense and by
her logic when she says only the people
who do the extremely hard jobs and the
difficult stuff are the ones who should
get the right to vote and do anything
then does it make sense to those people
are doing those jobs to see men who
aren't doing those difficult jobs also
get a right to vote also but you don't
want you want divorce to be made illegal
yes why yes because I don't think what
we have today is really marriage What is
marriage it's For Better or For Worse
for richer for poor and sickness and in
health till death do us part that's what
marriage is supposed to be but feminists
have ruined marriage for the people that
actually believe in marriage when
there's a 50 divorce rate and the
average man
I I didn't say that it was all down to
the women you asked why I want divorce
to be banned can I finish it first
she said can I finish yeah
don't let nobody finish my guy hey press
play
I'm about to start calling her just
masculinity
that's gonna be her nickname just
masculine things
just smelly things just manly things
yeah we're about to call and say hey
that's the new nickname for pearls we
were just lonely things and just manly
things okay let's keep going uh big
announcement we're going on tour what
yes we're on tour what are you gonna do
we're gonna react to videos live no
we're gonna do stand up
crack jokes maybe laugh maybe you don't
but you're gonna pay 75 to find out so
make sure you guys click the link in
description I think the first couple
days we're doing Detroit we're going to
be doing Washington Pittsburgh and
Washington so those are the three C's
we're doing this late summer end of
August and then after that we're gonna
be doing the rest of America we're
likely going to go to Europe some parts
we're excited to get to catch you guys
face to face leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for poor
in sickness and in health till death do
us part doesn't the sanctity of marriage
also rely on the woman being a virgin so
you wouldn't be able to get married
oh
whoa
that was petty let's go tell me you're a
[__] a homegirl didn't want to make any
arguments he said we going Petty yay I
made it I looked it up because I enjoy
it you not you not a virgin also I hate
whenever [__] Pearl says these vows
because they involve so many other
things yeah and she never mentions that
she she never talks about the laborers
she just says you can't leave that's a
remix yeah that's the remix and also
Pearl's fine with men stepping out of
the marriage
Christianity allows for divorce in case
of adultery
what do you what do you mean well you've
spoken quite openly about how you're not
a virgin and so if you want to preserve
that sanctity of marriage you know and I
just think that you're upholding
standards that you don't know
anyone here for some biscuits
[Laughter]
and went back and watched him you know
so funny because it actually flip that's
so hilarious what you look at men right
in terms of like their viability you
look at me and say he's a high value man
he's a medium value man he's a low value
man right I mean we could say that we
can put men into those categories okay
so let's say you're you're in the dating
uh field right you're you're looking for
a partner
right
um what do you mean I mean you're single
essentially I guess and you're looking
for significant maybe maybe not okay
just mainly things are single
okay so um
if you're looking for men
if a man who is willing to settle let's
say you're not that old but you're 26
and you say that anyone over 25 is
like uh almost damaged goods are getting
worse and worse no
it's less valuable it's less valuable
correct yes I would say I was more
valuable five years ago yes in terms of
today Market yes yes so do you think
that
how can somebody who's older and not a
virgin and less valuable how can they
get in a relationship with a man and not
think they're a loser
because if you're a low value woman then
in a sense you be judging the guy who's
settled quote unquote settling for you
because he couldn't get a higher value
woman so in a sense a guy that you would
settle for would be a loser by your own
by your own metrics low value what are
what are Men supposed to do 95 of women
aren't virgins on their wedding days you
could be a multi-millionaire and not get
a virgin
I think that's why you see more men
walking away from relationships uh no no
how do you enter a relationship and not
think that he's a loser because he's low
value
I don't really know how to answer that
question but it is interesting right
because in a sense only a low value man
and I'm sorry I'm only I'm only framing
this in your worldview let's say A
medium value man would would decide to
settle on somebody like you who's a
little bit older not as fertile not as
fertile you are not a virgin and also
they'll tell you something else you like
being in the foreground which is not
good for traditional marriages I mean
he's looking for someone who wants to
build a home you don't know how to cook
I don't I don't I don't expect to be
with like a high value guy I think
that's silly okay um when I when I think
of high value I think of like top five
percent of men so what value do you
think you'll be settling on in your own
personal life what
now this is the most Petty thing but
he's not wrong
but this is petty but I'm here for it
what value will I be settled yeah what
man do you think is reasonable for you
to pursue
I I just kind of I think that's a bit of
a inappropriate like question but maybe
that's inappropriate Pearl
you call women worn out baby mamas you
be asking women on your show all kinds
of things about the dating lives and the
dating preferences
that's your [__] job and now [__] is
now it's turned on you all of a sudden
you want to start stuttering that [__]
is inappropriate now inappropriate girl
have you seen your channel God damn I've
heard you call women whales to their
face say they're unfit to be wives say
they unfit to this and that and that was
you like what happened boo baby you
built the chair now sit in it what what
happened boo I don't like Ottomans
either
but it matches your hair stupid the way
you say stupid hit different yeah
because a little bit of irides I got
that from the New Yorkers no yeah no
that's not a that's not that's not
stupid no that is no because you put a
little bit of air in there it flows
better stupid that's Brooklyn and Queens
you stupid no no I don't say it with the
intonation no it is the same Vibe stupid
that's it that's the one right there
it's interesting because you spend like
all day talking about this stuff I find
that it's really interesting to have you
and animal put this analysis into use
how why is it the way you're framing the
way you're framing the question is a bit
disingenuous
um I think I think most women and you
know disingenuous
um
yeah I just I think it's a bit
disingenuous why okay see this is the
thing about Pearl if you just ask
follow-up questions and try to dig
deeper into anything she says it falls
apart she just says buzzwords her whole
Twitter is just buzzwords everything
says is buzzwords she's got the surface
level argument like a [__] robot she
got prompt one prompt two prompt three
that's why whenever he asks a follow-up
question to go deeper she just defaults
back to her talking points like well no
man can find a woman who's a virgin even
millionaires won't be able to it's like
we're not talking about them well why
are you changing the subject it's
because she doesn't actually think
through anything she says
and that's actually reflected in her
audience because her channel is dying
and it just turns out her audience after
listening to her for a while just
realized he's a robot and she's really
dumb but you don't see it until you
actually start to peer back and listen
long enough you're like wait this
doesn't make sense so now she being
exposed everywhere
like I think it's fair to say because
you were talking to women about
expectations and Men about expectations
based on their value I think it's fair
to say okay well what's your value of
man you're looking for based on your own
uh based on your own what's what's my
value to a guy that I'm no no no what
value I wish like I don't know what you
want me to say like I wish I I was a
virgin you know I should have waited no
no no no like I don't know why like I
don't I don't you know most guys don't
expect that in 2023 unfortunately
um I think men adapt to the market but I
think to say that you should just sleep
around
um so then
that's what you're saying so so if men
have adapted you know you don't really
care then why you still bring this
[__] [__] up why are you telling
women they're wrong if they're not
virgins men don't care I can honestly
say I've met a lot of dudes okay and
aside from the ones who are hyper
religious none of them care about
virginity now obviously they don't want
some girls got to only fans just popping
out of her [__] every weekend but they
don't care if she's a virgin I don't
think I've ever heard any of my homies
be like yo she better not [__] nobody if
I heard a guy say that I probably think
he's a loser too unless he's got
religious reasons then that's fine and
also to all the men who aren't virgins
but the men that are they women while
being like religious uh you goofy as
[__] too a lot of religious dudes want
to be the most nasty degenerate
[__] and you didn't use
religion to tell women how to act it's
like bro that religion also has Clauses
for you as a man just saying you're a
bit of a hypocrite actually no you a big
hypocrite and I'm saying it I'm asking
you a hoe too yeah yeah you out here
spreading all kinds of nastiness don't
don't even play that is a bit silly
that's not what I'm asking I'm asking oh
that you were saying that like that more
Partners is good I think that's a bit
silly um
I'm talking about you your value by your
own metrics is going to be not super
high
so yeah it's higher than it was five
years ago but it's not even just the age
thing it's like you are you are working
you're in the foreground you don't know
how to cook these are not good things
for your score I'm actually pretty I'm
pretty good now I've got you have a
couple pattern okay good you're working
towards it but unfortunately as you age
those things are going to bounce out
yeah I mean sometimes sometimes like you
start in a certain place in life but all
you can do is improve and get better wow
so Progressive oh my God no see Pearl
when she's past her Prime and her
value's low what does she say she
started sounding like them women I'm
better I'm better I can improve I no my
girl you didn't improve it's too late
according to you according to you but
like how do you meet a guy that you
respect because he's settling on you
don't you see that there's a paradox
here
I mean if you respect men you don't like
but how can how are you gonna settle for
a low value man because like that it's
like dude come on
a low value man I love that I think I
think if you get married you're lucky to
get married
how would you uh where's your value as a
woman would you say like on a scale of
one to ten I give myself like a five
facts
sorry let me stop with that I don't want
to keep going I love the fact that you
know as what Pearl is doing is basically
pushing all these men to get all this
girl so there's a hypothetically think
that all those men get all those girls
she's just like yes guys you got it you
got it you got all those
your eye value and you got all those
girls
and those curls or not me
you guys did it
So Pro
that's so lonely ah
you see all these guys exceeding and
they're not choosing you that's what
you're pushing them not to think
it's weird
yeah and you're scrolling all the women
that are trash
it's like yo you in the trash right now
and you're looking at me like
well you in the trash too
you're in the bin with me so it's like
you're telling all these girl ah what
are you doing man you stepping in [__]
while stepping inch that's wild
I don't know me watching these two back
to back I'll say this I thought the girl
that Pro was debating did a terrible job
yeah but hey you know what hopefully
we'll see Pearl back on Pierce and it'll
be more interesting in the future uh but
yeah I mean you know any opportunity.com
pro you can swing him my way I'm
definitely throwing that out of you I
got y'all put the lob up anybody want to
send me a lot we do win it we taking
turns okay because it's just easy just
mainly things can get that work what do
you mean pause how's that gay that's not
a silly girl when you say possibility is
it Gator it's sexual when you say pause
sometimes it's not just gay it's not
just a gay thing when it's sexual you
say pause it's not just gay it's just
gay but anyways I'll keep going uh but
yeah that's pretty much all my thoughts
on this anything else you want to say
all right well let us know what you guys
think in the comments below